a
[Música]
ah
cuando se cumple un año de la llegada de
la pandemia a chile tras varios meses de
ausencia este lunes abrían sus puertas
casi 2.500 de los 9.500 colegios que
existen en chile el retorno en las
clases será voluntario seguro gradual y
flexible aseguró el presidente del
gobierno sebastián piñera tras señalar
que más de medio millón de profesores ya
han recibido una primera dosis de la
vacuna y que el retorno a clases es
importante no sólo por afectar a la
calidad de la educación sino también por
acortar las brechas socioeconómicas esto
sigue a meses de polémicas entre el
ministro de educación y el colegio de
profesores que siempre ha firmado que
las condiciones no están dadas en chile
para un retorno seguro a las clases este
gremio aseguraba que sólo un 5 por
ciento de los alumnos regresaron el
lunes de forma presencial y que el 90%
de los colegios públicos retomaron las
clases de forma telemática apenas dos
días después ya había esos y cinco
colegios en todo el país en cuarentena
por haber detectado casos positivos de
cobijo
[Música]
este lunes se iniciaron las clases en
educación primaria secundaria y técnica
en uruguay a diferencia del año pasado
la concurrencia es obligatoria y
presencial según datos oficiales el 80%
de los alumnos de primaria concurrieron
y el 60% de los de secundaria en dos
liceos del norte del país las clases
debieron de ser de forma remota por
casos y contactos de kobe 19 decenas de
centros de estudios fueron adaptados
para poder seguir los protocolos
sanitarios especialmente el de
distanciamiento físico y todavía se
sigue asignando docentes para los mismos
sin embargo el sindicato de maestros y
trabajadores de educación primaria
analiza un paro de actividades para el
próximo lunes criticando las condiciones
edilicias de los centros educativos y el
recorte en cantidad de docentes y
horarios asignados en relación al año
pasado
[Música]
por la pandemia de koi 19 argentina
estuvo prácticamente sin clases
presenciales durante casi un año
finalmente el 17 de febrero comenzó el
regreso de los estudiantes a las aulas
un proceso que todavía continúa cada
provincia lo está haciendo a su manera
pero en general se combinan clases
presenciales ya distancia alternadas
entre semanas los protocolos también
incorporan distanciamiento físico y
medidas de aislamiento por grupos si
aparecen casos de kobe 19 para llegar a
este punto hubo fuertes discusiones en
las que algunos sindicatos docentes
argumentaban que no estaban dadas las
condiciones para volver a las aulas
mientras que muchos padres y autoridades
pugnaban por el regreso finalmente se
fueron alcanzando acuerdos y los
trabajadores de establecimientos
educativos se convirtieron en
prioritarios dentro de la campaña de
vacunación y ya comenzaron a ser
inoculados esto es clave para intentar
asegurar que este año no se interrumpan
las clases presenciales algo que por
ahora no está garantizado
[Música]